overwhelming breeze the tanzanian city
of mora Goro mourns the death of dozens
of people killed in a fuel tanker
explosion coffins lined the funeral
venue as families bury their loved ones
I've got time I think that I mean that
we need to keep aqui aqui he was about
to leave the area but then the explosion
happened he tried to escape but it was
too late he was already on fire burning
and screaming the vehicle overturned on
Saturday
crowds rush to collect leaking fuel
moments after an explosion left bodies
scattered on the ground many burned
beyond recognition
the government says DNA testing will be
offered we have enough doctors and DNA
specialists so our team will make sure
they do whatever it takes so that all
family members can identify their
relatives and bury them survivors were
flown to a hospital and Dar es Salaam
for specialized treatment many have
severe burns on over 80% of their body
when the fire started I began to run
away but I got burnt when a man tripped
on top of me I was able to push him off
but then a second person fell on me
President John Mago fully visited the
injured and declared three days of
national mourning
we have seen the patients some are doing
very well but most important for us as
Tanzanians is to pray for the sick and
for those who lost their lives the
explosion is the latest in a series of
similar disasters that have killed
dozens of East Africans in recent years
distraught families are now trying to
cope with the pain as they say their
final farewell katia lupus of the yawn
al-jazeera